good evening
my name is linnea shively and i'm a
freshman here at hillsdale college
intending to major in political economy
and minor in journalism it's an honor to
introduce our speaker tonight
christopher effo is a senior fellow at
the manhattan institute and founder and
director of battlefront a public policy
research center author of the recent and
primus essay critical race theory what
it is and how to fight it he is a
graduate of georgetown university and a
former lincoln fellow at the claremont
institute for the study of statesmanship
and political philosophy
as executive director at the documentary
foundation he has directed four films
for pbs
including most recently america lost
which explores life in youngstown ohio
memphis tennessee and stockton
california he is also a contributing
editor of city journal where he covers
topics including critical race theory
homelessness addiction and crime
please join me in welcoming mr rufo
all right
how's everyone
good good uh
good to meet you i think i see some of
my uh students from this last week i've
been teaching a one credit journalism
class um all of the students present
we'll get an a in the class so
congratulations
over there well done
um
well let's see what we can do let's get
in some trouble tonight maybe i know
that this is being recorded in live
streams so
i'm hoping to say something interesting
and noteworthy in the next 30 minutes or
so
um the topic tonight is laying siege to
the institutions
um and so the question is what does that
mean
but before we can answer that question
we have to know the context in which
that question must be asked
and so i'd like us to take a step back
to the period that none of you remember
you're all far too young the period of
1968. um
if you look at 1968 it was really a
turning point a very kind of paradoxical
and contradictory turning point in
american history um you had then all of
the
left-wing ideologies that seem so
dominant in our institutions today
being born
in the months or in and around 1968
you had the birth of identity politics
you had the idea that
the united states could be overthrown
through cultural revolution
and then you had
the very beginnings of militant
street activists
that had sought to
what they believed used urban guerrilla
warfare to achieve their political
objectives
and i think many of the
stories that i work on many of the
phenomena that we see many of the public
policies that some of our friends on the
far left and places
like seattle or san francisco or new
york or chicago are proposing
if you actually look back and look at
the literature look at the manifestos
look at the uh
publications of that era
you see a remarkable similarity
it's almost as if we're living in
permanent repeat of some of those ideas
the only difference unfortunately is
that in 1968 it was also the year that
was
uh the election of richard nixon
not exactly a fire-breathing leftist
and so
you saw this left-wing movement burn out
over time by the mid-1970s the groups
like the black panther party the black
liberation army the weather underground
or their counterparts in europe uh in
germany and italy and other countries
that had sought to really capitalize on
what they saw as a world historical
change
in 1968
had met really a sad and divided end
they were infiltrated by law enforcement
uh their campaign for urban guerrilla
warfare generated discontent especially
in the communities that they claim to
represent
and so by the end of it there was just a
few dozen
angry disillusioned demoralized radicals
the fbi had swept up many of them
and what you sense in the literature and
the history of the time and you could
read it in all of the journalistic work
the letters the essays some of the
academic work
is that they realize that this moment
had been lost
they looked at it as the victory of
counter-revolutionary forces embodied
most prominent united states by richard
nixon
but really at the heart of it the lesson
that they learned at the time was that
the working class in the west
in western europe and most especially in
the united states
could not be roused to revolution
the class-based idea
that you could have
the suppressed workers or the oppressed
workers rise up against their bosses in
the factories in places like
detroit michigan
was doomed
and in fact working-class americans
were not only non-revolutionary they
were anti-revolutionary
they were actually satisfied with a
rapidly rising standard of living uh
with benefits and privileges that their
parents and grandparents could not have
even imagined perhaps when they were
immigrating from europe uh in the
decades prior
and so this immense frustration
by the time you hit the 1970s is really
evident at all of the work of the of the
period
and so they settled on a strategy of the
long march through the institutions
they realized that they couldn't set off
bombs in the u.s capitol as they tried
to do
or assassinate police officers shooting
them in the back of the head at
point-blank range in new york city as
they had done a number of times
but they actually
formulated a new more sophisticated and
frankly very successful strategy
of abandoning hope that the lumpen
proletariat so the outcasts of society
uh people who are truly the downtrodden
and forgotten remnants of the american
class system
they really abandoned hope that they
could be part of this revolution they
said we're going to go a revolution of
the intelligentsia a revolution of
elites
by seizing control of not of the means
of production um you'd be hard-pressed
to get some academics running a factory
line in detroit
but through the means of culture and
knowledge production
and so what you see is these washed up
radicals in the 60s 70s really 80s
migrating into academia
and then migrating bringing their ideas
uh for example uh uh in the 1970s
out of the radical manifestos the
marxist-leninist revolutionary
manifestos and into formalized academic
work
what i've done we're going to fast
forward we have a little bit limited
amount of time but what i've done in the
last two years
is report on the state of our
institutions today
i've looked at the federal government
i've looked at the universities i've
looked at fortune 100 companies and i've
looked at k-12 schools and what i found
is something that i think is shocking to
most americans
you're taking the core concepts that
were developed in that period after 1968
they've been sanitized
adapted
repackaged and repurposed
and then injected into american life at
the lateral bureaucratic and
institutional level
so you have an idea that seems somewhat
frivolous maybe
somewhat ridiculous like white privilege
that's being taught in many stories that
i've reported on to kids as young as
seven eight nine years old
that children in a classroom can be
separated into oppressor and oppressed
based on identity categories based on
skin color
and then deemed oppressor and oppressed
and then the kids in the public
classroom let's say in cupertino
california they recently did this for
third graders
should atone for their white privilege
some of it seems a little goofy it seems
a little bit uh uh
ridiculous
but the origins of white privilege
theory again we're from 1968 it was a
marxist leninist theory the idea is that
you'd have to break down working class
notions of white privilege in order for
them to join
the marxist revolution
and so the purpose and the origins of a
lot of these ideas as you go down the
line um all emerges from that point
and now has been
transferred
through
uh academic literature through k-12
pedagogy through
masters in education programs
uh through k-12 curriculum modules
through hr programs human resources
departments at corporations
and i think what we find ourselves in is
a a maze of postmodern language that is
the other element that is grafted onto
the revolutionary rhetoric of 60 70
years ago now
and it's a language of
obfuscation
it's a language of euphemism
and it's a language of demoralization
and so as many of you have been
following for example the fight against
critical race theory
one of the fights that has been really
going on for a year almost to the point
of absurdity
is this euphemistic game of well what is
critical race theory that's not critical
race theory critical race theory is an
obscure legal theory only found in upper
division law school classes
oh well your
k through 12 elementary curriculum says
critical race theory on the cover it's
using all the principles of critical
race theory that couldn't be it couldn't
exist
that's diversity equity and inclusion
and so you get these
ideas that are wrapped in language
that is meant to obscure
or meant to
be impenetrable or unopposable
i think none of us very few people uh in
certainly the united states and to a
lesser extent but also in the world
would oppose diversity in the true sense
of the word meaning having a variety of
experiences
interacting with a different variety of
people this is why
americans travel this is why you go
overseas you want to get a diversity of
perspective and culture opinion history
that's not what it means in practice
though the next term equality or equity
rather
it appeals to this idea that's a homonym
with
with equality
and yet the significance of it is the
exact opposite
equality is the idea that each
individual should be protected under the
law regardless
of characteristics that might be
grouping them into a
that might be separating them into
different groups or categories this idea
that no matter who you are where you
come from you'll be treated equally
under the law
equity takes the opposite view it would
replace the system of individual rights
with a system of group identity based
rights
and that your merit or your worth or
your position
uh or the material resources that are
divided and then distributed should be
based not on your individual
potential or character or work or
accomplishment but based on on your
group identity
that is
takes no account of your individual
characteristics or
excellence
and so
what i've tried to do in my reporting is
to surface all of these
very
dense and very euphemistic phrases and
and terms that you're probably seeing
popping up everywhere
you're probably seeing it at work you
might be seeing it in your kids k
through 12
school curriculum
you're certainly seeing it in the
political sphere
um and our federal government is
absolutely saturated with it and it's
trying to make heads or tails it's
trying to make sense of this language
it's trying to get to the heart of what
this these words mean
because i think that only then you can
truly have a sense of how you can defeat
it how you can fight back
because what i've seen over and over
in my reporting looking at original
source documents is that every elite
institution in the country
that has
dominance over knowledge dominance over
culture
dominance over even in many cases
material production
has converged on a unitary ideology
it's really a remarkable thing
the hr training program at walmart for
example
is the same as the
fifth grade
education module in public buffalo
public schools
is the same as the diversity and
inclusion training program
at the department of the treasury in
washington dc
all three of examples from my reporting
and it's a very kind of basic list of
concepts derived in this case from
critical race theory that says the
united states is fundamentally an
irredeemably a racist country
the country today is saturated through
with systemic racism
uh
in the racial categorization of citizens
in the here and now it can be divided on
the axis of oppressor and oppressed
based on race
and people who are deemed white or
in some cases white enough like asian
americans strangely
um
you have to atone for your privilege
you have to
bankrupt your privilege
and then if you want to be re-accepted
back into society after that process
you have to submit to the political
ideology
that regards not freedom and equality
not the constitution
not the principle of equal protection
not even the system of individual rights
but moving to a system of collective
group-based rights
moving to a system that is explicitly
anti-capitalist
you have organizations for example like
american express
preaching that capitalism is
fundamentally racist
american express uh teaching that
capitalism is fundamentally racist
um
and so on and so forth and
one of the great curiosities for me was
how is this even possible i'm sorting
through
documents from
5 000 different sources
all over the country from every kind of
institution from all walks of life
how is it possible that it's been
distilled down to these key
say seven to ten ideas
that are then
implanted into the organizations through
the bureaucracy
so it's either the dei bureaucracy
that's kind of the most common one now
human resources is another one there's
all sorts of different euphemisms that
that get
constantly created and recreated
but the ideology is the same
and the ideology is really
indistinguishable at its essence from a
lot of those materials that we saw in
1968
and so the question is what can we do to
fight back
i'm going to talk about tactics and then
i'm going to talk about strategy
as far as tactics i've been uh i've been
tasked and and asked to talk a little
bit about a story that i broke last week
uh while i was teaching the journalism
students here at hillsdale college
about a company called walt disney
um so any news watchers in the room
yeah okay
so you've probably heard about this
scandal really with the walt disney
company
um i've actually been reporting on walt
disney for more than a year off and on i
have some good sources inside the
company i broke a story last year that
walt disney company was forcing
employees to engage in a critical race
theory training program
which denounced the united states as a
fundamentally racist country
asked its white employees to complete a
white privilege checklist
and then advocated for all of the
fashionable causes
i believe they had exercises in there to
decolonize your bookshelf
whatever that means
and any kind of these pedagogical
techniques or or kind of fashionable
self reflection exercises that you see
in all these corporations disney was
doing it um after i broke the story
disney's first uh first attempt was to
deflect
they used this they sent out this
amazing press release actually they said
um you know because people were
criticizing they said this is racist
you're dividing your employees along the
basis of race
they've created racially segregated
employee groups
uh employee activist groups
they're denouncing the country they're
denouncing a large part of their
employees and their their customers on
the basis of skin color and disney said
in a press release no no we can't be
racist we made the movie black panther
um
which is a kind of
bizarre corporate variation on the uh
you know the old joke about i can't be
racist i have black friends um it was
really a kind of
ridiculous moment um where they were
caught you could see between the lines
of the press release totally off guard
because in the elite milieu
this is something that is not even
questioned
in fact the disney employees who leaked
me these documents and in the video said
you cannot question it
you can't say a word
you have to be silent this is the new
orthodoxy it's the orthodoxy in every
elite institution if you want to keep
your job you have to shut up
disney eventually
deleted their entire program from their
internal website
so a big victory for me that's always
fun um
but of course these things get deleted
temporarily but they always resurface
because it's not that
it was well-intentioned people that they
made a mistake or they had a document in
their server or part of their training
program that they didn't agree with
these things are baked into the
bureaucracy
and so last week i was
sent a series of well i was sent
actually the full video an hour and 40
minutes approximately
of disney's internal meetings
regarding its very political and very
public fight with the governor of
florida
a man named ron desantis who signed a
bill
i think very simple bill
that simply said
you have to keep
education on gender ideology
sexual orientation and sexuality
out of the classroom between the ages of
kindergarten and third grade
this seems fairly common sense i think
it has depending on the polling
questions somewhere between
60 and 80 percent support
an overwhelming number of americans
but the activist groups within disney
were furious
because they believed that disney as the
world's largest entertainment
corporation
certainly the largest entertainment
corporation in human history
regarding kids entertainment
they believed that they were the moral
voice on children and sexuality
and that they wanted to
not only oppose the legislation but use
all of the levers of corporate power to
fundamentally reshape the narrative
about kids and sexuality
and so i released a series of videos
last week
um
that had for example an executive
producer saying that she was
deliberately with the support of her
colleagues
in inserting what she called a quote not
so secret gay agenda into kids
programming targeting kids as young as
two years old
another another disney employee a
production coordinator said um that he
was he had created a tracking program uh
to make sure that the company was
including enough
transgender
uh
non-binary and asexual characters i
think i have those terms right
um
and this whole series of statements
which you might imagine happening at
maybe uh the women's studies department
at vassar college
but i think rightly concerned a lot of
people
when it was high level executives
saying we are going to fundamentally
change
the relationship between kids and
sexuality in the united states
by reshaping the by engineering a
narrative
based on gender ideology we're going to
do so really secretly they didn't make
an announcement about this
while at the same time we're going to be
publicly opposing any legislation that
would provide a restriction on this
in public schools
and so
this was
in short i think a scandal for disney
um they were very
tough they were kind of chest-beating
executives had gone out prior to this
story
saying what they were going to do
talking trash to the governor
committing to overthrowing this bill and
overturning it
and then after they were really pummeled
i think fox news mentioned this story
300 times in 24 hours at one point last
week
the new york times wrote about it um
they said this was all fine until chris
ruffo got a hold of it
tried to blame me for it
um
and then the company went fairly silent
i think it probably also has something
to do with those poll numbers we talked
about
where a huge
a huge majority of not just
florida voters but american voters
american adults said hey wait a minute
this is too much
we don't want to have
gender ideology being taken from the
university
being and being forced on
kindergarteners
behind the backs of parents without
informing them about what's going on
and this is something we've seen over
and over and over whether it's critical
race theory or gender ideology
and so i think we've struck quite a blow
disney was trending on twitter which is
i think a kind of a distorted
approximation for for what's in the news
in some ways
uh for an entire week
um you had conservatives boycotting
canceling disney subscriptions anyone
cancel a disney subscription in the last
week
okay good that's at least 500 a month or
whatever
you had a lot of people cancelling and i
think you had a lot of americans really
raising questions
what's happening with our institutions
what's happening with kids
i also discovered that
playing a bit of hardball
when a company enters the political
debate
on the issues of children and sexuality
my argument was that well we should
actually examine their record
on children and sexuality
and to my somewhat surprise
i found out that the walt disney company
has had a notorious pattern
at least once a year for the last decade
and then
before that as well
of having employees arrested for child
sex crimes
child pornography child exploitation
child rape etc
and not only that that's obviously bad
enough it appears from the coverage that
it is a disproportionate number the polk
county sheriff who's adjacent to
disney's uh operations in in orlando
florida it seems like every time he does
a sex thing he nabs at least a few
disney employees
um disproportionate i would imagine
based on the limited evidence uh to
their rate and the uh in the in the
labor force and so my point is that when
a company is claiming the moral high
ground on these issues of children and
sexuality
um we should look at their record
and of course they're not responsible
for everything their employees do on
their own time but i also found a few
stories as well
disney for example allegedly
disney authorities allegedly told
their cruise ship security guard
to keep her mouth shut when she
discovered
that one of the disney employees was
molesting a young boy on the cruise ship
which allowed him to evade arrest and
then disney flew him back home to india
so he couldn't stand to be accountable
and also the disney's cruise ship
lobbyist association the trade
association of which disney is a member
had advocated against had opposed and
then significantly watered down
legislation that would have required
disney and other cruise lines to report
sexual abuse on its cruise ships in a
timely and stringent manner
and so i think
the lesson of this
is that the institutions in the united
states that have adopted these
ideologies cannot be appeased
they can't be easily shifted from within
they've been captured at the
bureaucratic level
and disney has the perfect case study
disney executives have delegated moral
authority within the company and
political authority within the company
to internal activist organizations
whether they're in the race and sex
segregated
identity caucuses or in the human
resources departments
and so what it's going to require is not
a long march of the institutions i think
most conservatives uh don't have the
ambition of one day being a
diversity and equity uh director at a
public school district
um
you know uh
whatever that might look like
so the strategy is not to say well let's
march back in let's let's have a kind of
counter march i think the strategy is
quite different it's an actual siege
strategy
it's from the outside
and it's taking on our
superior public support
because whether it's critical race
theory or gender ideology in schools for
example
we have about a two to one margin the
public supporting our position and
opposing the position of the
institutions
these institutions don't choose these
ideologies democratically
you didn't vote for it i didn't vote for
it
they're imposed anti-democratically by
fiat through bureaucratic not democratic
rule
and so what we're seeing i think as the
first step
is a narrative and symbolic war
against companies like disney for one
example
you have to be very aggressive
you have to fight on terms that you
define
you have to create your own frame your
own language
and you have to be ruthless and brutal
in pursuit of something good
the second strategy is mobilizing
popular support we're seeing this at
school board level
after the reporting that i did and some
other colleagues had then picked up on
about critical race theory in public
schools
i saw this amazing emergence organically
of
irate parents
coming home from work tired in their
dress clothes
showing up at those school board
meetings and giving hell to those school
board officials did you see any of these
videos
yeah
and we know for a fact
that these parents didn't know what was
happening in the classroom
they never voted or approved of this
and when they found out what was
happening they were livid
and so parents are getting mobilized on
that grassroots level
to oppose this kind of ideological
capture in those k-12 school districts
and when they won't listen which is much
of the time
parents who have organized and run
campaigns are winning overwhelming
elections
we're talking 70 30.
if you put your name on the ballot in
the median
school districts in the united states
and you say i'm the anti-critical race
theory candidate i'm going to get our
education system back to the basics of
reading writing math etc
prioritizing excellence
over ideology you're going to win
in many places at that 70 30 level
i think reflecting overwhelming public
support
and i think the
the third step then
is to decentralize
because a lot of these
problems emerge because of
centralization
because of bureaucratic rule
because of control by a minority of
permanently
publicly subsidized activists that have
turned public institutions
into private ideological organizations
and i think when you look at schools as
another good example we can talk about
universities maybe if we have a little
time
but when you talk about schools there's
no reason
that if you're a parent
you don't have the means let's say to
send your kid to private school or
parochial school
that you should be stuck in a public
school based on your zip code
that violates your child's right to
conscience
that shames or demoralizes your child on
the basis of
race or identity
and that you're allowed no
recourse through the bureaucracy
and no escape mechanism
there's no reason why we can't have for
example universal
school choice
so that a family that says you know what
this isn't for me this violates our
family's values at a deep level
shouldn't be able to take that average
of fifteen thousand dollars a year
and move it wherever they want
it could be another public school could
be a charter school it could be a
private school this is controversial i
don't know why but could also be to a
religious school
because what's happening is that you
have 90 of public school student of
american school children attending
public schools
you have 90 percent of american
university students attending public
universities
you have a monopoly
that unless it's broken up unless
parents are given more power more
freedom more options more choice
they're going to be forced to run their
kids through a gauntlet that they can't
control
and so i think if you
categorize them all together to
summarize very briefly
you're engaging in a narrative war
i mentioned earlier that there's this
kind of post-modern
uh uh uh
layering
on top of all of our institutions
to turn the
let's say revolutionary ideology into
something very gauzy very vague
um very seductive very attractive
soft language
um
we have to rip that veil off of really
what's happening and show
americans through reporting through
information through investigation
through public records requests etc
exactly what's happening
and we have to fight at that narrative
and symbolic level we live in an
information society
and if we are unilaterally outmanned on
that front
it's impossible to gain traction
someone could go to the school board
meeting and literally not have the words
to oppose what's happening
and so that's what i've tried to do what
others are now also doing
is providing people
a kind of key
into explaining beyond the euphemism
exactly what's happening
what those words mean
ripping the cover off of that language
and providing them with a renewed moral
language
to be waging the fight
not within the confines of
the opposition's framing but by creating
a new frame
and so with critical race theory for
example
it creates an entirely new frame
you're fighting substantively accurately
but also with language that you can
point to you can go to a school board
meeting you can explain and you can
oppose
and the evidence shows the from polling
data that's been done
kind of sequentially over the last 18
months
18 months ago let's say two years ago
round up
percent of the american people
knew about critical race theory
in the last 18 months we've brought that
number up to 75 percent of the american
people
and we've turned it into a two to one
issue
which in politics i don't know many of
you are in politics um if you um
go to say let's say a campaign uh
manager and you say hey we have a two to
one issue uh i mean they're going to be
salivating and drooling and
you know
calling in ad buys immediately
that's a decisive victory in a otherwise
fairly evenly divided society
the second is to attack the credibility
of institutions
this is something that i think
conservatives have been rightly hesitant
to do for many years
well we like our institutions
um
i think conservatives are really
realizing now we like what our
institutions were
we like what we imagined them to be
and now that we are seeing what they are
we don't like them as much
and so luckily the institutions are
really doing this
to themselves you see trust in all of
our institutions cratering
i think it's foolhardy to say well we
really want to just raise that number
i think you want to create the
conditions for fundamental
structural change to bar to appropriate
some language
for example school choice
to get universal school choice
you really need to operate from a
premise of universal public school
distrust
because in order for people to take
significant action
they have to feel like they have
something at stake
i think that
the public schools have done a
remarkable job at doing that for
specifically the public school teachers
unions
they shut down schools for more than a
year
in some districts half of all kids never
showed up to online learning
they've had the most catastrophic
learning loss likely since world war ii
they're ma they kept kids masked for
years while the adults
traveled around the world with no mask
on
and the teachers union endorsed
promoting critical race theory in all 14
000 local school
districts and i think
finally and the positive side of this is
we have to create alternatives
i think that in a dynamic society like
the society that we have
we also have the opportunity and the
responsibility
to create alternatives
and
in many cases i think uh
many of us
have
and many parents for example i include
myself in this
for for for a while not anymore
um
got complacent
well you know kind of send my kids to
school should be fine kind of like what
i had growing up
um and
i just don't think that that's a
realistic option for people anymore
and when i talk to parents for example
all over the country they're desperate
for new ideas
new options
you have now 5 million
american kids in home school
there's just been an explosion in
homeschooling
you have even the hillsdale charter
schools that are now expanding
parents are desperate
for intellectual entrepreneurship in a
sense political entrepreneurship
rather than just simply fighting about
who gets what uh actually creating
something substantive that matches
people's values
and so
before we take questions
i'd just like to
close by
repeating the stakes by resetting the
stakes rather
um
i i really think that the key dynamic
for us to all be thinking about
is not necessarily even a left versus
right
dynamic
it is that that's important but
i think where the opportunity lies is
really a
top and bottom dynamic so a
uh kind of elite class
that represents a very small amount of
people
that has positions of influence within
uh the kind of knowledge-making
institutions within pedagogical
institutions that has designed and
implemented and distributed all of these
ideas that we're finding in the
reporting
and the vast majority of the american
people who are still
attached to the idea that america is a
force for good
that their kids should be protected
from radical ideologies being imposed on
them and
the tender ages of elementary school for
example
and that our country
in some ways has gone off the rails
and they want a sense of security they
want a sense that people are fighting
for them and i really think there's a
common intuition
um of all of the
uh uh
the good that can still be raised into
our institutions raised into our country
maybe not in the exact way that it looks
now
but in the way that it could be
and so
i really think it's up to all of us
you could be maybe
on offense there's some of us i think me
included
that really are
just built for offense
and there's some that are built for
creating institutions
for playing defense
for protecting the civilizational values
and virtues
uh that should be continued from the
past into the future
and i think that if we
are just taking these two
polls these two
systems these two world views
we really have an option between
the the revolution
of 1776 or the revolution of 1968
and i think one of them offers
a method for
this
incredible unfolding of those founding
principles of freedom and equality and
the other one ends up in nihilism
and despair and demoralization
it ends up in a
bombed-out bunker in greenwich village
in the 1970s
and so
i would suggest to you even though even
some of you who may not be
temperamentally uh uh predisposed
um
that the best strategy in the immediate
term is the siege of the institutions
um and that we should prepare for the
fight thank you so much
[Applause]
questions
thank you mr rufo we will now have time
for some questions if you have a brief
question please make your way to a
microphone
awesome thank you so much for your talk
chris sure i want to
touch on something that you said here in
your talk about narrative warfare one of
the biggest problems i think we face
right now is uh social media censorship
um so you know you broke this story
about disney on twitter um and obviously
you have a lot of clout there and the
story can spread like wildfire and
that's obviously a weapon that the left
can use is to simply silence those
voices they don't like and so in some
ways it feels that the position in the
narrative war is very fragile
what are some of the ways that you think
we as conservatives can get around the
very obvious opposition we face from big
tech um
one of the thoughts that i've had is
that um attacks on the monopoly status
of many of these firms is absolutely
necessary um
to to ensure that we have the platform
to be able to spread the message like
critical race theory thank you great
thanks great question
i think that uh the disney story is a
perfect example of it of a potential
answer or at least a suggestion of
answer
um
you know one of the things that i
personally like about the governor of
florida um
and i've been able to actually work with
his team on policy on some of these
issues
um is that he's not willing he's not
unwilling rather
to stand up to
big companies even the big companies in
his state
i think he recognizes that our
corporations
should ultimately be serving
the common good should be serving the
country and he understands also that
the political power is ultimately higher
than business power
um and
through the legislature uh we can set
the rules of the game
if there's censored anti-censorship
legislation i think there's some common
sense regulation that could happen uh to
protect people um
accepting that uh you know the digital
communications infrastructure is
uh the new public square or the digital
public square
and i think you also wield power for
example against a company like disney
if disney is actively undermining uh the
the families and voters of of say
florida
um i know that i've been looking into it
and this governor desantis has been
looking into it and
congressman jim banks for example from
nearby and indiana is looking into it um
well let's see if we can level the
playing field a little bit
disney gets massive tax breaks from
florida legislators are looking into
those
the congress has extended disney's
copyright um essentially doing their
bidding in perpetuity
multiple times longer than what the
founders had intended in their 28-year
copyright limit
and republicans including jim banks
have said clearly when disney's
copyrights on things like mickey mouse
expire next year and they come hat in
hand to congress saying you better
extend it you better extend it
conservatives are going to say
no we're not going to extend it we're
going to allow those things to go into
the public domain and so i think you can
in some ways
remind companies
that uh the deal that corporate
executives thought that they had
in the last few years is
we've we've already won with
conservatives we bought them off we have
low tax rates we have competitive
economic environment
it's better to be a big corporation than
a sole proprietor or a small business in
in the united states
and so we've won
we've bought them off on economic issues
we bought off the ride and so we're
going to buy off the left on culture
issues
um and they're finding out that that
relationship can can shift and the power
can can change and so i'm optimist then
you have wild cards like elon musk uh i
mean
i i don't know i don't know anything
about him personally i never met him but
i mean
uh i i i think there's just uh
there's just a feeling right now that we
can tap into
um to to to maybe channel that teddy
roosevelt spirit uh where we want to
have free enterprise we want to have
free competition but what we don't want
to have is uh cartel organizations can
ideological and economic cartels
dictating the terms uh from up high down
to the average person
and so i'm optimistic about all that
i thank you for coming and i appreciate
what you said i can't wait to revisit it
uh online but um my wife and i moved up
here in 2013 to put our kids in
hillsdale academy to get them out of the
public school system so i appreciate
that we did what we needed to do there
and we did uh cancel our disney account
this week well done past week i've been
needing a reason to do it it's been
itching but that's not what i wanted to
ask you i despise the term racism
um because i believe we're one race
right there's different counts of
melanin in a person's skin
but we're one race and i despise that
term because it is
it
breeds division
and what would you say how can we
overcome that particular term one of the
beauties of americans america's tapestry
is that we come from so many diverse
ethnicities and and tribes and nations
and tongues but we're one nation
and how what would you suggest i i would
suggest that that people the the vast
majority of people
agree with you in the sense that
um we are
one nation
we come from all over the planet i mean
really unique a unique composition of
people
and that we want to have narratives and
especially pedagogies
that inspire kids
that help kids transcend
maybe their differences
aiming them towards excellence aiming
them towards
their greatest accomplishments
and
you know as you look at the public
polling data it's very clear
the manhattan institute released uh
polling data from america's 20 fastest
growing cities these are places that are
very diverse a lot of young families
people trying to move their way up the
ladder live the american dream
and the numbers were quite clear among
parents
parents opposed lessons on critical race
theory
systemic racism and white privilege
by i believe a 42 margin
overwhelming
and this includes a majority of parents
who are white
black
latino
asian
so majority of every racial demographic
and they want to have an education that
says
that speaks to them the values of all of
these
everyday people i said look i just want
to have my kid uh have a chance
to come up in the world to do better
than i could do
to get a great job to raise a great
family and these are kind of the
the humble
but but universal building blocks that i
see people tapping into every day and
they sense that it's going to be crushed
by these people who occupy positions of
enormous power and privilege
that simply have
this
poisonous and nihilistic ideology
wherever it comes from where whatever
its lineage is that they want to impose
from the top down
and so i think the best way to overcome
it is not to be a pollyanna you have to
acknowledge the historical existence of
racism in the united states for example
but always put it in the context of the
country's highest ideals and the
country's steady progress towards
realizing them
and i i think it's a unifying message
and wherever i go people i talk to from
all different backgrounds
um
you know as long as you're not uh you
know
at the new york times building or
something uh
um it's something that they want and
they need and and we have to be unafraid
to talk about it
chris thank you for your thoughts one of
the things that bothers me is the total
chaos in the country i mean i i wouldn't
trust the fda the cdc for sure the fbi
is equivalent to the gestapo
and maybe the cia uh the military i
don't know if they're for fighting a war
or fighting gender wars
what do what do you think about what's
going on in
society beyond critical race theory it
seems to be a total meltdown of trust in
any of the institutions on any of the
issues be they science or whatever
yeah i i mean i think the answer is
pretty simple there's been a rupture in
trust because a lot of the institutions
have been untrustworthy
that's the simple fact i don't think
that people are
are have have the trust numbers have
plummeted because
our institutions have been so wise and
virtuous and fantastic that uh and we're
just the ungrateful kind of plebes you
know below
um
i mean look at covid
it's you know in a lot of cases this is
not my area expertise but
from just a personal point of view
um
all of these things that were conspiracy
theories
so-called conspiracy theories by you
know the science and capital letters
turned out to be true
you know whether it's the lab leak or
whether it's well you can't get covet if
you have the vaccine or you can't pass
it along or we need to have endless
masking it's the most effective
uh plan i mean
you you look at the politics that has
been embedded in all these institutions
and then you look at the decisions
i think i saw you know the the most
heartbreaking numbers for example of
businesses that collapsed in the coveted
lockdowns
those are people's life savings
their livelihood
their whole
dream the whole thing they've worked
towards
you have teenagers that lost out on
their high school experience
you have skyrocketing rates of
depression and suicide
among kids
and then you turn around as people our
parents are trying to say i'm trying to
keep a job
i'm trying to keep my business afloat
i'm trying to make sure my kid doesn't
sink
into the abyss
i'm being lectured on television
and then i i i drop into my kids uh uh
you know third grade social studies
class
and he's being lectured on critical race
theory
it's a very simple response to people's
everyday experience i think and it's i
mean it's too bad it's awful
but i i don't think that
i i just i've kind of learned this maybe
the hard way
but
these problems aren't going to be solved
by asking very nicely and politely
for the people and positions of power to
pretty please do a better job
and you know what else is something true
related
you know something i'll share an
experience from disney you know
the other thing that we need to stop
doing
is allowing or or is limiting our
arguments
to things that are deemed appropriate
by
liberals
in journalism you wouldn't believe
i mean the kind of self-censorship talk
about the the biggest crisis is
self-censorship it's not even getting
banned from social media
um
in the sense that well you know
i did i wrote the story about hey what
is disney's actual record
on
child sex crimes let's be honest about
it
you can't say that
you oh that's just absolutely horrible
yeah that's that's out of bounds
no it's not
and i think if we internalize and and
and this is you know there's depends on
how online you are uh but
there's a kind of a classical liberal or
a centrist liberal or a kind of
kind of like a bill maher type
appealing to people
in that category will get you nowhere
and do you want to try to get the kind
of plaudits or the approval of people in
that circle
uh in the kind of left liberal media
environment and and follow their kind of
rules of discourse and debate and
language
or do you want to actually align with
the
60 of people
who are fighting for their companies
fighting for their jobs fighting for
their kids
that are represented by legislators at
the state level on the federal level
that are actually going to get the job
done
and too many people in my world in my
field of journalism
they choose the former and i like to
think that in 15 20 30 years
they're going to realize wow i was
really polite this whole time
but i didn't achieve anything
and so i'd rather be impolite
i'd rather get in a little bit of
trouble
i'd rather
make some of the
you know prominent people a little angry
and actually deliver results
and so i think we're doing that with
disney i i think the story for example
with these videos
it generated at a very minimum
150 million media impressions
um you know i i think that it's almost
certain now that republicans in congress
will not extend their copyrights next
year when they expire
that's a multi-billion dollar hit to
disney um
and you're not going to get that done by
being really polite and following all
the rules i hate to say it sorry kids i
hope to you know
but uh be polite at hillsdale um to your
teachers and your administrators but out
there you know toughen up
right here
mainly the
1619 project that's been influenced on
crt
okay question 16 19 project
i i've said this a number of times
the 1619 project is a epic phenomenon um
it is a
ephemeral creation that people are going
to forget about in a in a probably a
relatively short to medium period of
time i i don't think it makes a lot of
sense to get too worked up about it um i
think that it's it can displace a lot of
attention from the deeper uh issues
about the ideology where it comes from
how it works bureaucratically um and i
i'm personally not too worried about the
1619 project
in a sense i'm not saying it's good i
don't like it
but in the in the sense that i don't
think that the 1619 project is like uh
it is gonna do grave damage uh i think
that there are
we have to really
keep our eye focused um at a much deeper
level
and the the question is how do you blow
up the transmission belt
that delivers the 1619 project to
millions of school kits
and if you blow up the transmission belt
um
the new york times is going to be stuck
with a lot of copies of the 1619 project
you know
we have time for one more question all
right great
this question is about blowing up the
transmission belt thank you for all you
do for opening our eyes um
casol the social emotional learning
company that k through 12 schools look
to for their social emotional learning
they are now promoting equity with
excellence in education
how do we
crank out more non-woke teachers
from our woke universities and still
be able to label them as excellence when
uh
the academic world says oh our
public universities are excellent
uh you know
we have to have certified how do we uh
we do have a way to do that great
question and and we do um there there's
a couple of ways i'll talk about maybe
the most uh effective way
look a lot of this i know michigan is
kind of a a purple state purple state
would you consider it yeah okay um
but even red states i talked to people
in red states
how do we deal with this horrible
problem of our public university system
i don't know you're the state
legislature you pay for it you pass
appropriations bills for it
uh it's under your jurisdiction
and every day every year you just write
a blank check
to the public university system
these are public universities
that should reflect and transmit the
values of the public
and the representatives of the public
i.e state legislators have ultimate
power to shape or reshape those
institutions
and so we have to get out of this idea
that somehow public university system is
a
is a totally independent entity
that practices academic freedom
a total fraud that's a just a false
statement fundamentally false
and that you can't touch it or else
you're uh impinging on the rights of uh
uh you know the gender studies
department to to to follow their dreams
you know
um i mean
it really is that simple and the
legislators you talked to oh yeah i
didn't think about that
because it's such in the background of
our experience we accept it as a given
we accept it as the status quo that we
can't even examine
but i think legislators are starting in
florida they're doing it in texas
they're doing it they're starting to say
hey wait a minute
why is every
taxi driver
short order cook
and plumber
in my state
paying six-figure salaries for a
diversity and inclusion department at a
public university
where these folks are making three four
hundred thousand dollars a year
and you look at their job description
it's it's understandable what they do
i mean it's it's it's it's
you're you're funding private political
activism with public dollars so states
can say no more public dollars for that
you can take it away
i think another thing that that states
can do um and and and should do is
saying
well we're going to actually open a new
branch of our public university system
let's say let's say the flagship
university of michigan ann arbor
conservatives let's say have both houses
and the governorship in michigan for
example a policy you could pursue would
be to say we're going to have an
independent board of directors appointed
by the governor
and we're going to have a
conservative
center
that is independently governed within
the university of michigan or the
university of texas
and then you create a magnet for
conservative professors you create a bit
of debate within the university you
create a variety of perspectives you
create a diversity of courses
and you're creating a separate
patronage system
some people don't like thinking about it
that way but guess what
the public universities the dei
departments the public school
bureaucracies are at the end of the day
patronage systems for left-wing
activists
and as long as there's going to be a
patronage system wouldn't it be good to
have some people who are representing
the the public within them i think the
answer is probably yes
and then for teachers specifically
um there's absolutely no reason
that teachers need a master's degree
to teach reading to third graders
and in fact all of the academic studies
which are by no means
right leaning or conservative
they show that teacher credentialing and
teachers masters programs
have zero relationship with quality
teaching in the classroom
and in fact many people education
scholars whom i trust
say that it actually does significant
damage
to the public school workforce
because you have
the craziest people in charge of
departments of education i mean really
truly
the number one most assigned textbook
for
master or graduate level departments of
education
is a book called pedagogy of the
oppressed by paolo ferreira
he was a brazilian marxist leninist
whose greatest claim to fame was running
the educational propaganda
for
the marxist-leninist governments in west
africa after decolonization
and he very famously ran the education
program for guinea bissau the the west
african nation
and some scholars went back uh years
later and he was heralded as this genius
of education bringing education to the
countryside educating the peasants palo
affairs teaching everyone to read
they actually studied the results
they couldn't find a single example of a
single person that learned basic
literacy under his programs
and guess what american public school
students are doing better than the
public school students in guinea-bissau
for sure
but you still have about a quarter of
them never achieved basic literacy
despite education spending doubling or
more
in the last generation or two
generations
and so the simple answer is say from the
state level past legislation
there's no financial benefit and there's
no requirement for teachers to get
advanced educational credentials degrees
masters etc
and you can have someone who's say a
history major at hillsdale college
uh that is excited wants to learn how to
teach
can get a job teaching history at a at a
public school there's no reason that you
couldn't have a system as simple as that
and what that does is it cuts out
this uh um cartel essentially you have
to pass through the the graduate school
of education cartel if you want your
piece of paper in order to teach you
have to go through their thing so they
have a captured customer a captured line
of business
get rid of it
say no more statewide if you want to go
you can go spend your own money it's not
required and guess what i think nobody
would go
truly i really feel like maybe some
you know lunatics would go and that's
fine but then you look at them and say
you say the ones that don't hire the
ones with the masters because those are
the crazies um so i i think a lot of it
is look public policy is the greatest
tool that we have
almost all of our problems are are
created by public policy almost all of
the worst ideologues in our society are
permanently subsidized by public dollars
and so we need to have the courage and
the intelligence and the tenacity to say
what the public giveth the public can
take it away
and so we get in there we defund things
we don't like we fund things we do like
and we try to break up the system so
that ultimately we're taking power away
from those centralized authorities and
giving it back to everyday people
because i spent a lot of time at both
both parts of our society in the kind of
fancy parts and in the kind of everyday
parts and at the end of the day i would
trust people
at the in the middle and that big bottom
making sane and rational and wise
decisions and so the more we can put
power into their hands the better we're
going to be so i appreciate it thanks
everyone for coming out
[Applause]
thanks again chris for our guest we have
a hospitality just out here in the lobby
you're welcome if you leave hungry it's
your own fault so
for students go do your homework
you